the literary world versus film and
television parallels differences in
terms of making a living getting work
out there for me it's so much of writing
I've done for money was never a
motivating factor and as you know in the
arts it's a rarified if you actually
make money from it it was quite
wonderful when in third grade I won I
not I went in third grade I got sixty
dollars for being paid for a story I
wrote that was in plays magazine a
protagonist that was male called the
flower that grew overnight and to get
that check for something I wrote I was
addicted I'm the difference between
television and writing on your own I
love being in a writers room I love that
I love the camaraderie I love everyone
coming together and working on something
if I could do that all the time I would
it it's my favorite thing I have a
friend that I wrote a script with and I
absolutely when you're with other
writers and they're they're good it's
playing tennis with someone that can hit
the ball back I hate when you're playing
with someone and they can't get it
because if I'm stuck and I can't getting
you know they can and that'll inspire
you to whack the out of that ball
and you're like oh there's nothing else
like it I love it
you